[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER: The man of the hour,
ladies and gents, Mr. Eazi.
Let's celebrate that.
Come on.
You sit here.
Give you that one.
So the light streams here.
MR. EAZI: All right.
SPEAKER: All right.
MR. EAZI: Yo.
SPEAKER: So you know, I
was advised not to do this,
but I have to ask.
Can you start us off with
the signature, it's your boy,
Zaga Dat?
I can't-- I can't do it right.
I can't do it right.
Can you?
MR. EAZI: It's your boy Eazi.
Zaga Dat.
SPEAKER: Hey.
AUDIENCE: Hey.
[APPLAUSE]
SPEAKER: All right.
Thank you so much
for joining us here.
MR. EAZI: Yeah, thanks man.
SPEAKER: I know you've had a
crazy, crazy travel schedule.
Stage at SXSW, sold out
crowd on the East Coast.
Sold out crowd on this
side of the country.
Congratulations on all that, and
we're happy to have you here.
MR. EAZI: Likewise, man.
SPEAKER: Awesome.
Awesome.
So get started man.
As we were putting
this together,
you know, you get
Africans in a room,
they always get energetic.
People started arguing
about where you're from.
Is he Nigerian?
Is he Kenyan?
So we said we'll just ask you.
Or does it really matter?
MR. EAZI: I think
it doesn't matter.
I'm always trying to run
away from that question.
You know, but I'd like to think
that I'm Nigerian by birth.
SPEAKER: OK.
MR. EAZI: And then maybe
Ghanaian in the heart.
AUDIENCE: That's right.
MR. EAZI: You know,
because it's so funny.
Is like, who I am
today is as a product
or as a result of
both countries.
Beats birth or stays cool life.
I think I've lived most
of my aware life in Ghana.
And I don't [INAUDIBLE]
Ghana, but--
it's
SPEAKER: Let's give this
guy there his [INAUDIBLE].
Well, that's super exciting.
And you know that's one of
the things that makes us
really excited about Mr. Eazi.
That emphasis on it just
being African, and connecting
across the board.
But how did you end up in Ghana?
Can you tell us a little
bit about the story?
MR. EAZI: I was done
with high school in 2006,
and then I remember I wanted to
go to Ontario to do aerospace
engineering.
And then I think the fees, was
like, almost like 15 grand.
Right?
And then I had to
go to the admission,
and then I go to my dad,
and I told my dad, "Yo dad,
I've gotten admission, so you
need to give me 20 grand."
And then my dad, he
is like, oh, 20 grand?
I'm like, yeah, and that's just
fees, because I bumped it up.
Like, that not pocket
money and [INAUDIBLE].
So whilst he was
thinking about it,
my mom just shows
up with my sister,
and they say, oh, we've also
applied for you to go to Ghana,
and the fees is just 5,999.
There's aerospace,
but we're able to get
you mechanical engineering.
And you take almost
the same courses,
so you could start
with mechanical
and then do aerospace masters.
And my dad made the
economic decision.
So he gave the excuse
that, he's like you know,
your mom have some
extended family in Ghana
and is good for you to bond
with them, and you know,
become African.
So I go go Ghana, and before
I knew it I was in Kumasi.
My mom actually lied to me.
She's like, don't worry,
Kumasi is just like Ontario.
Exactly the same,
with better weather.
So yeah, I found myself
doing mechanical engineering,
and I fell in love
with the place.
SPEAKER: Yes.
Yes, yes.
That's amazing.
And the banku
addiction was born.
So how did that
transition happen
from mechanical engineer,
studying mechanical engineering
to the Mr. Eazi
that we see today?
MR. EAZI: I think it is funny.
I'd say it was born
out of the fact
that I always wanted to be
economically independent.
So I remember in
my second year, I
went to Nigeria,
University of Lagos,
and then I found an old school
mate who was doing parties.
So every weekend he would host
big parties, and at the time
he was writing a [? choral ?]
And that was the big deal.
This is like 2009.
And so, I just
thought to myself,
how can I start writing a
[? choral ?] in my school?
So I went back to school.
At the time, my school was Kwama
Nkrumag University of Science
and Technology. .
I think we have
alumni over here.
So my school was
very, very serious.
Like people at the time just
used to focus on their studies.
And so I came there, and
I'm like, you know what?
Let's start partying.
And I'm like you guys
can't only learn.
You need to also party.
So I started doing parties.
That started being
very successful,
from parties, to concerts,
to fashion shows.
At some point it was hard
for me to mix it with school,
because I was in the
club almost every time.
And I feel whilst
doing the concerts,
I started booking some of the
biggest African artists, both
in Ghana and Nigeria
to come to my school.
And before I knew it, I
was in studios with them.
And then somewhere, somewhere
after grad, I started my MSC
and I just had so
much free time.
And I was sick of clubbing
because, I'd done it all.
So I start going to the
studio as a relaxation.
And before you know it,
somebody is listening somewhere.
Oh, Mr. Eazi, we love you.
SPEAKER: OK.
During your master's?
MR. EAZI: Yeah,
during my master's.
Specifically around the time
I was doing my [INAUDIBLE].
So during my
[INAUDIBLE], it was--
I had so much free
time, and for somebody
who's used to activity,
I was almost going crazy.
So I just needed
something to do.
And I remember one of my friends
who I'd booked in the past,
he just took me to the
studio for like two weeks.
And we were recording,
and he said, oh, we'll
call it "About to Blow."
So we called it The Mixtape.
We called it "About
to Blow, The Mixtape."
We put it on SoundCloud.
At that time, I didn't
even put my face,
because obviously, I was trying
to have a different career.
So I didn't want people--
I didn't want to go
to job interviews,
and then the guy would be
like, are you not the guy
who's singing somewhere?
I remember, I started
playing with cartoons.
So I'd have this
friend who would
do animations, and
disguise my face so nobody
would know it's me.
So yeah.
SPEAKER: Nice, nice.
What were you people doing
during your master's?
How did you get the parents
on board for that transition?
Everybody here that
knows African parents--
Was mechanical
engineering, you're
doing your master's, and now--
I want to do--
MR. EAZI: So you know
the thing is, is that's--
The thing is, my mom
and my dad always
thought I was just joking.
Cause, you know cause, obviously
I was was still in school.
I was still doing my master's.
And to prove to them that I
was still doing my master's,
I would send them my grades.
So, they knew I was--
SPEAKER: The real ones.
MR. EAZI: Yeah, the real ones.
So they knew I was
still in school.
And then, I got a job.
I got a job in a company
called Schlumberger.
Schlumberger does well
services, testing, drilling.
It was a huge deal at the time.
SPEAKER: Still is.
MR. EAZI: Yeah.
And I worked there
for like eight months.
SPEAKER: Oh wow.
MR. EAZI: And I was
doing really good.
And I was still
going to the studio,
so to them, they just thought
that that's his hobby.
I feel there wasn't
much need to convince
them, cause I only decided
to do music full-time July 22
last year.
So in July last
year, I get booked.
I go to London, and then I
have two events in five days.
I have a festival
that had 8,000 people.
And four days later, I had
booked also Kentish Town,
that had almost 3,000 people.
So in the space of five
days, I had 13,000 people
had come out to watch me.
Plus, I had made over a hundred
grand pounds in those five
days.
So when I called my
dad, I'm like, yo dad,
I just made a hundred grand.
He's like 100,000 what?
I'm like 100,000 pounds.
He's like from doing what?
I say yo, is like, I'm
a musician right now.
He's like, oh, that's very good.
That's very good.
I need to change your name
to Mr. Eazi on my phone.
So there was no need
to convince them.
You know, cause like, I'd
basically already proven
that I could generate revenue.
And for the 10,000 people
to come watch you, it was--
I had the metrics basically.
Basically my dad has
always been about--
He actually gave me a deadline
of around that time last year.
Because after I finished my
MSC, I started doing my MSE,
I started doing some
gold trading business.
And then I moved back
to Nigeria and started
a tech company, Phone Trader.
But I wasn't really
generating good revenue,
so he just told me, you know
what, you have till July,
till the end of July,
and if you're not
generating funds from whatever
company you're pushing,
you might just have to go
back to work in Schlumberger,
or come work with me.
Because he does ad-hoc
aviation services.
So I basically--
I was about to run
out of my deadline,
and then I start making
revenue, so he's like, OK, cool.
I didn't need to
convince anybody anymore.
SPEAKER: That's amazing.
I think a lot of
Googler's ears perked up
as you're talking about the
metrics, and the revenues.
People are hearing
some of the language
that we speak about every time.
One of the things
that we know is
that it takes really great
people, and really great teams
to make anything amazing.
So tell us a little
bit about the people
that we don't see that
are behind the scenes.
MR. EAZI: Yeah, I have a very
small, very close knit thing.
Because of the way the
music just snuck up on me.
I remember the first time, the
first ever booking I had was
to go to the UK.
And at the time,
I had no manager.
So I had this friend
who worked at Vodafone.
He's a very big marketing
guy at Vodafone Ghana.
So I called him to
act as my manager.
So we walked into
the meeting, and I
was like this is my manager,
he works at Vodafone.
You know.
And basically we started
working together as my manager,
and he started handling
my affairs in Ghana.
Especially marketing,
marketing myself in Ghana.
And then I reached out
to my former rival.
So in Uni, I used to--
At some point I had
monopoly, because I
was the only one doing parties.
Then a year later, my current
manager, [INAUDIBLE], goes--
He was understudy me.
He was like my boy,
he was at my parties.
And next thing, he
goes to start his own--
he goes to start
his own company.
So I'm not going to
lie, I hated him.
I felt he was he
was a snitch, cause
why would he be on my team
and suddenly go start out his?
So I remember, any time I saw
that he was putting events up,
I would put my event
the same day, just so
that I could flop his event.
And I remember one time,
his event flopped my event,
so I couldn't take that defeat.
I'm like, geez.
So I called him up.
I'm like, you know what--
The truth is, I knew
he had taken over,
cause he was under younger--
He had the younger people
coming to his party.
And I was about to
graduate, so they liked him
because they felt oh, he was--
And he had so many fine
girls coming to his party.
So I walk up to him.
I told him,
[INAUDIBLE], you know
I'm the king of
this party business.
I want to help you, I don't
want your parties to flop.
Meanwhile, it was
my party flopping.
And I told him that
we are not enemies,
the people are the enemy.
So you know what we'll
do, let's collaborate,
and I would host a party,
and you will host the party.
But we're the ones
behind both parties,
so that the customers will
feel that they are going to--
They will feel a
sense of competition,
and some will go to yours,
some will go to mine.
But at the end of the day, we
are still the ones behind it,
and we make money.
So we created like a
false competition scene.
And so we started doing
parties and concerts together.
So once it was time to--
Once I started seeing that
the music was getting real.
At the time he was in South
Africa, because he's a pilot.
So I just told him, and he
started handling my bookings.
Because he was the
one that used the book
the artists back
in school, he was
very good at negotiating deals.
So we rose from from--
The first ever booking I got was
like two grand, and by the time
he came on board, the next
booking we got was 10 grand,
12 grand, and we
just kept rising.
So the team is just basically
the marketing lead in Ghana,
then [INAUDIBLE], then I
have my high school school
mate, who is now
my DJ tour manager,
then we have two people in
Nigeria who handle live events.
And that's basically it.
Every other person
is like ad-hoc hired.
SPEAKER: Yo, that's amazing.
Such it's a small
team, do so much.
It's incredible.
I hope you guys are getting
your business school notes here.
Because you can't get
this stuff from class.
Let's switch gears
a little bit less.
Let's talk about the music.
I think one of the exciting
things that you've talked about
is how this kind
of snuck up on you.
But the music doesn't sound
like something that snuck up.
It sounds like-- It's
a sound that people
feel like they just always had,
that they've been waiting for.
What are some of the
influences, and how did you
get to that identity?
MR. EAZI: I feel like
music is, for me, music
is an expression of myself.
And I'm a big believer
that human beings
are like a product of
their environments.
And since the music comes from
the soul, it now defines me,
and I'm like an
easy going person.
And then I've been influenced
by the cultures of Ghana
and Nigeria, and you could
hear that in the music.
It is a mixture of
both influences.
And I feel for me, all the
times I was going to the studio
just to mess around, I
was actually practicing.
I was learning, because I have--
I'm sure if you
went back to Kumasi,
if you went back to that studio,
you would see maybe 100 songs.
And I can assure you
those songs are whack.
You know, but all those
times were formitive times.
And yeah, by the time
I was ready to put out
the music properly, I just stuck
with what I had been doing.
And I feel like there was the
need at every point in time,
and it will happen
in the future.
The sound always changes.
And trends, even in
fashion, trends change.
And it's like a circle, it
goes round, around, around.
And so the trend
was about to change,
and I would just there to say
be the instigator of the trend
change.
You know, it is what it is.
SPEAKER: Capitalizing on a
opportunities of business
and music all around the board.
So who are some of the folks you
were listening to growing up,
that you think you
hear now in your music?
MR. EAZI: I listened to a
whole lot of music growing up.
I listened to--
Because my dad was a
huge Bob Marley fan.
So I listened to a
lot of Bob Marley.
I listened to a
lot of Dr. Alban.
In my Uni days, I got--
because of my roommate,
I got stuck up
listening to a lot of
Jay Z, Lil Wayne, Drake.
You know.
And yes, and of course a lot of
Nigerian music, like Lagbaja.
And I feel like every
song I do, there's
a different part of that
influence that shows.
"Bankulize" was one
of my first records,
was originally a Reggae record,
before "Juls" switched it
up to what it became.
And that's why I call it
banku music, because it really
is Afro fusion music.
Because in the bass is African
drums, and African feel.
By the end of the
day, I draw influences
from all genres of music.
SPEAKER: Oh, dude.
Banku music, Shitor, Tilapia.
There's a lot of
music about the food.
MR. EAZI: About food.
SPEAKER: About the food.
What's that about?
MR. EAZI: I think
I'm a low key foodie.
Low key.
I believe if not for--
I feel like I have
a quick metabolism.
If not for that,
I'll be really huge.
I don't eat too
often, but when I eat,
I eat like for three people.
You know, so so--
And you know for
me, since I was not
doing music to
become a superstar,
I was doing music as a hobby.
So I had the freedom to
call my songs anything,
to say anything on the records.
Cause there was no intent of it
going beyond me or my friends.
So it was as easy as, ah,
my friends eat Shitor.
We love Shitor.
So like oh Eazi, make
a song about Shitor.
So I go to the studio,
and I make a song Shitor.
It's crazy, oh we eat.
There's even a song I
have called "Plantain,"
because I love plantain, and
we made a song about that.
So I feel it's cause there was--
I'm a foodie, that's
why those names.
And because I was
just feeling free.
And I feel for me, if success
would continue for me,
it's will have to be
about me not really caring
about making a hit record.
I would have to be sincere
every time I'm recording.
And I feel is this
sincerity that people--
SPEAKER: Connect with.
I have to say, that's
definitely something
I've heard consistently.
That in some ways your songs are
almost bigger than Mr. Eazi is.
Like a lot of people
know the music.
They've never seen the guy.
They don't really know
who the person is.
And it seems like that
was by design initially.
As you kind of move
into this next phase
where the music
is blowing up, how
are you thinking about that,
and about your publicity,
and your personality,
like shining through?
MR. EAZI: Yeah, it's so
interesting to see that.
Like I and my team,
we basically see--
Now, I'm going to be saying Mr.
Eazi as like as a product, not
myself.
So we basically see
Mr. Eazi as a product.
Right?
And it is in the same vein,
if you had to product,
what you need to do is you
need to test the products.
You need to go through
testing to be able to define
the market for the product.
And when you define the
market for the products,
you run test to see if
the said market actually
buys in to the product
you're selling.
when you decide that, you
go on and do marketing.
So now your marketing
is not going
to be broad based, it's
going to be very direct--
SPEAKER: Direct.
MR. EAZI: --because you already
know who you are marketing to.
And is the same thing we've
been doing with the music.
We found out that
Africans in diaspora
were the first to
embrace the music.
And we started targeting
our markets and our touring
to Africans in diaspora.
I remember, [INAUDIBLE] would
look up my YouTube views,
and he would see that the UK was
number one streaming position.
And we would just talk based on
stream data and even the store
that's the same way.
But that's why right now we're
doing a diaspora tour, reaching
out to the first fan base.
And then to answer
your question, in June
we want to do a very
huge, both digital,
and above the line
marketing campaign.
Which we already started
with the mixtape,
which is billboards.
I think we had 25 billboards
across Nigeria and Ghana,
with Life is Easy on it.
We had the London buses,
the London city buses.
SPEAKER: [INAUDIBLE]
MR. EAZI: We had 12 routes.
We had the city buses
in Lagos as well.
And we will start a proper
marketing campaign called
Who is Mr. Eazi in June.
This time I would have my
face fully on every add,
and we would run
it both targeted
at our diaspora
audience, and then
back home, African audience.
So by last quarter,
by Q4 of this year,
everybody should know Mr. Eazi.
SPEAKER: Should know Mr Eazi.
more worry about
the job interviews.
Dude, that's amazing.
You started talking a
little bit about YouTube,
so let's chat a little bit
about this online platform
that you guys are using.
And I know there are a lot of
people in the room interested
to understand how you
guys are using technology
to power this zero to
1,000 rise that you've had
in the last year and a half.
MR. EAZI: Yeah.
I'd say my success at this point
has been just as a result of me
leveraging on an online product.
So for instance, I'm
very big on Twitter.
It's almost as if I'm
on Twitter 24 hours,
and that's cause if
I'm not tweeting,
my team member in
London is tweeting,
or somebody in Nigeria
is handling the Twitter.
But what we-- and
this was [INAUDIBLE]
shout out to the
manager in Ghana.
He just said, you
know what, if we're
seeing Mr. Eazi as a product,
then almost every company
spends a healthy amount
of their budget trying
to connect with the
consumers, trying
to connect with the customers.
So what we started
doing was, I remember,
we would search on Twitter.
We would search Mr.
Eazi, and everybody
who mentions anything about
Mr. Eazi, we would retweet.
We would say oh, zaga dat,
zaga dat, zaga dat, zaga dat.
And my fans started to
see it as something huge.
I remember I would see, all
oh my God, Mr. Eazi just
replied me.
And someone else
was following them
and doesn't know Mr. Eazi
would be like, who is Mr. Eazi?
Why are you excited?
Next thing, when we see
that trend, we would follow.
We'd say a SoundCloud link.
We would be like oh, this is Mr.
Eazi here, listen to his music.
SPEAKER: Yeah.
We will just have
to pause there,
so people can
understand the marketing
magic that was just dropped.
A mouthful, that's amazing.
MR. EAZI: So we were
taking our time to do that.
It was hectic, but
we saw it work.
What we began to
see is that even
though we didn't have a lot
of followers on Twitter,
until now.
I now have a lot of followers,
but the interaction on a tweet
was more than the
average interaction
for an artist who was bigger.
And this was because the fans--
It was now a personal
relationship.
Like till today, I still, at
concerts backstage, I still
meet fans who call
me by my first name.
Hey, Tosin.
And I'm like, I don't
know this person,
but just because of our
relationship on Twitter.
And it was the same thing
we did for Instagram.
For instance, we started to do--
Even as cheap as $10 a day,
$20 a day Instagram ads.
And let's I go to a
show and I shut it down,
we will take the
video clip and we
would promote it,
to try and target
between Ghana and Nigeria.
We'll promote it and we'll
see our followers rise,
or we'll see people paying
more attention to our music.
So it was, we were
heavy on Twitter,
we are heavy on Instagram.
We started doing
work on Facebook.
And then I remember, we
started doing YouTube ads.
I remember one day, I don't know
where, I think I was in Ghana,
and I was about
to watch a video.
And then I saw
another video play.
It was for an ad.
Maybe it was for
Nescafe or something.
I saw it play before the
video, and I had to watch it.
I had to watch it for
at least six seconds.
And then I said wow, I
think we need to do this,
and we basically started
doing the same for my videos.
And I feel like that just
basically-- that's the tool,
and it's been very effective.
It's been cheap.
We've not needed to get
outside funding for Mr. Eazi.
SPEAKER: Yo, that's
awesome to hear.
Are there any challenges
that you guys are having?
Because we have a lot
of people in the room,
thinking about these products.
Do we have any
YouTubers in the room?
OK.
We have some
YouTubers in the room.
Thinking about these products,
and thinking about ways
to make them better
for your use cases,
are things you're trying to
do, pulling in this data.
Is there anything that, you've
been looking at this person,
like man if it just did this,
we would be so much happier?
MR. EAZI: I feel,
for us, we've been--
And I think I'm right,
we've been kind of good
with the services.
For instance, we registered
to use the YouTube
Space in New York, to shoot like
a dance video for my mixtape.
We thought that
was very cool when
we found out that, you know.
We've also been using the data.
The only thing is,
that for some countries
you can't trickle
down on the data.
Say for the US, you could
trickle down to see, OK,
it's New York,
it's Austin, it's--
And so we are better
informed to tour.
We know that if we have a steady
20,000 streams from YouTubers
in New York, then we could
do a 2,000 capacity show.
In New York, is a no-brainer.
But we can't do that
for some of the cities,
because it's just broad, to
just country-based data you see.
Yeah, and I feel like
we're just trying to--
It's something I
was starting with.
We're just trying to see
how to use the ads well.
Because I feel like we are
just learning on the job,
and it's providing
amazing results.
And you can imagine, if
we were proper, proper.
We proper knew how to use
AdWords, and use all these ads.
We'll be like unstoppable.
SPEAKER: Awesome.
Awesome, awesome.
So all the YouTubers in the
room, I hope you're listening.
We have some data people
in the back [INAUDIBLE].
We need to drill in on
some of these countries.
So cool.
We're almost out of
time, so I'll just
jump to kind of
the tech start-ups.
I know you talked a
little bit about them,
but tell us more
about the businesses.
You know, where they ended
up once the music started
blowing up.
MR. EAZI: Yes, so I was in
this incubator program called
[INAUDIBLE] TNG,
and that day I got
to work with a lot
of programmers,
a lot of innovators.
For instance, there was
this app called Pass.ng.
Pass.ng is a testing app.
So basically, there's
a test you take
to get into Nigerian University,
which is called the jump.
Now Pass.ng.
has all the test questions from
like 20 years back, on the up.
And then it makes it
a fun way to test.
And then the more you
test, you get freebies.
You could win stuff.
And then people pay--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
MR. EAZI: Yes, give
me [INAUDIBLE].
People pay via the
networks, say, pay via MTN
or pay via [INAUDIBLE].
So that's one of the products I
was involved with studying on.
And it still works now.
I believe last time
it was generating
like 50 grand monthly.
50 to 100 grand monthly revenue.
Then, Phone Trader still works.
We have seven
outlets in Nigeria.
SPEAKER: So, what
is Phone Trader?
MR. EAZI: So Phone
Trader is like--
How do I explain it?
Phone Trader is like
a car phone warehouse.
What we do is, we
buy used phones.
So say for instance, there's
about to be a new, maybe
for instance, the Samsung
Galaxy S5 is about to drop.
Then we would--
Since we operate
from the telcos,
we will have people
come out, and we
will buy the S4s
from them, and we'll
give them discounts on the S5.
And we will in turn take the
S4s, and do a mini refurb
and sell the S4s with 30
day warranty to customers.
So we would basically
do that across a couple
of brands in Nigeria, and
we offer repair services.
So you could find out
how much your phone
is worth by going on the website
and entering the details.
And Phone Trader is
still operational.
My friend runs it, because
obviously I'm somewhere else.
And ultimately, what I'm
trying to do is get to a point
where I can merge the brand
Mr. Eazi with the products.
And even within, I'm searching
for like tech products that
are relevant to the
music in Africa,
that I can launch at the point.
See, when I have--
Because the music
gives you influence
and is as easy as me
saying oh, use this app,
or use this service.
And people would
just go just based
on the fact that Mr. Eazi
says those we should use it.
Yeah, exciting, exciting times.
Looking forward.
SPEAKER: That's amazing.
If you guys have start-ups
that you're trying to pitch.
Get ready now.
Get him for five minutes
after the conversation.
So what's next for Mr. Eazi
as you're kind of going this--
go through this next phase?
I've heard some
rumblings of Eazi Core.
MR. EAZI: Yeah, so
basically since it's--
This is no more a joke.
You know, cause like there's
a lot of people involved.
SPEAKER: 50 million streams
later, Eazi realizes.
MR. EAZI: There's a
lot of people involved.
I mean, I've played shows
in places like Ukraine,
done like two shows in Ukraine.
SPEAKER: That's amazing.
MR. EAZI: I've gone to Dubai.
SPEAKER: So who is the
audience in Ukraine?
MR. EAZI: So it's funny,
Ukraine has thus far been--
OK, next to Cyprus,
it has thus far
been my most diverse audience.
Ukraine was the
first place I got to,
and I look in the
crowd, and I'm wondering
are these guys
here for Mr. Eazi?
I'm like seeing everybody, not
just Afrikaans in diaspora.
I'm seeing everybody
there, and I'm wondering--
SPEAKER: That's beautiful.
MR. EAZI: And I
remember in Ukraine, I
was singing this song,
and I go up to this chic.
And then she's Scandinavian.
And then I'm singing,
and I put the mic,
because I really want to test
to see if she knows the song.
And then I put the mic,
and she's singing it.
And in my mind I'm
like, what does she even
know what she's singing?
You know so, it's not--
We've realized it's not
a joke, because we're
doing good revenue.
We're having a lot of people
who are positives on our PNL.
And now, we've seen that,
we've changed again,
we've just destructed
how African
music used to be put out.
We've leveraged on
technology to put out
the music in a cheap way.
We've hit people online, and
because it's buzzing online,
the radio is forced to take it.
We've never had to sell the
seats for any radio play,
or TV play, or interview.
It just comes based on the
fact that we're online.
And sometimes I spark things.
I see things on Twitter,
just to get people riled up.
To keep the conversation.
SPEAKER: Start the Twitter wars.
MR. EAZI: You know, so--
We're about to launch
what's called Eazi Core.
Eazi Core is supposed
to be a platform
to break African artists, break
African artists in general.
Both in an Africa
and in diaspora.
So it will just be a
management platform where
we help you put out your music.
We help you do marketing.
We do an 80-20 partnership
with you, so we,
as a management take 80% of the
revenue, and you as the artist
takes 80%.
And you still have
the independence.
And so we're in the
process of that.
We're in the process of doing
huge JV type, or distribution
type of publishing type,
basically partnerships
with bigger organizations.
so that once you put out
your music in Tanzania,
it can immediately
get across Africa in
diaspora with just one email.
You know so, that's basically
what we're working on.
And we're also working
on the marketing
campaign we want to launch
which is, Who is Mr. Eazi?
SPEAKER: Who is Mr. Eazi?
Awesome.
So guys, we're going to
shift into questions,
live questions and
Dory questions.
I'm going to have the first
live question, because there's
something I want to ask about.
Thank you so much Tonya.
You just hit on the
success in the Ukraine,
and this globalization
of the African sound.
You were recently covered in
"Vogue," "New Sound of Africa."
A lot of really
exciting things, Wizkid
signed here in the States.
21 Savage, as well.
What is going on with the
proliferation of the sound?
And it a good thing?
Is it a bad thing?
How do you see it?
MR. EAZI: I feel like
it's a good thing.
I feel like, with
all due respect,
I feel like African
music is the new reggae.
You know, is the new dance hall.
SPEAKER: All right.
Let's pause right there.
Get your Twitter fingers ready.
MR. EAZI: You know,
it is exciting.
But I feel like this
excitement and this move
has been powered by
Africans in diaspora.
And is being powered by
an order to call it dance.
Because African music
is very redeeming,
there's been a lot
of dance related--
I feel has been followed by
dance, and it is exciting.
And dance is a language
everybody understands.
And it's only going
down to the artist.
So it's good.
I just feel we as
African artists just need
to be able to benefit from it.
Like if someone like Bob
Marley could move reggae music
from Jamaica to the world,
there should be African artists
who spearhead this movement.
And I feel it is a
global space now.
There's nothing hidden.
Everything is on the internet.
So we just need to
position ourselves well
to be partakers of--
I'm sounding like my pastor.
Be partakers of the new wave.
SPEAKER: Awesome.
What Can people in this
room do to make sure
that African artists
and Africans in general
are partakers of that next wave?
MR. EAZI: I feel,
first off is like--
And is something we always do.
I feel like the first
thing is like education.
You know, education.
Like letting people know
things that can be done.
Partnerships.
Like everything we've done has
been a lot on partnerships.
For instance, we've been
partnering with streaming
platforms, and
they've been giving us
banners in countries outside
of Nigeria and Ghana.
So I remember when I
released my mixtape,
I had banners in Germany, in
Korea, on the storefronts.
And that way, I had
people from there--
OK who is this guy?
Let me listen to the music.
So I feel like if
there's anybody
that has the power to
actually break African music,
it's the tech companies.
Because they have platforms that
the whole world is logged onto.
The whole world is on
YouTube, is on Facebook,
is on Apple Music, is on
Spotify, blah, blah, blah.
And partnerships like
that would help elevate.
For instance, I
might have a concert,
and get it live streamed
and have some ads around it.
Things like that, basically.
And if you guys can give
us like Google credits.
[LAUGHTER]
SPEAKER: Well, you guys
heard it live and direct.
I think we have our
assignments, our work to do.
With that said, let's
jump to questions.
Do we have live questions in
the room to get started with?
AUDIENCE: Hi, yes.
So my name is Jeff.
You mentioned that you do
have people on diaspora who
are listening to you, and
you also have local artists.
Right?
Or local audience.
So how exactly do you
go about making sure
that you're not alienating
maybe the people in diaspora,
or sort of like the more native
words that you might say.
Maybe you say a few words,
or [INAUDIBLE] words.
How do you make sure
that you're not sort of--
Which yeah.
How do you target your audience?
MR. EAZI: So basically, the
thing like I was saying,
I thought that there would
have been a direct need
to water down the lyrics.
So water down the use
of indigenous terms
and language in the music.
But like I said, I went out
to Ukraine, and I was singing.
I think I was singing
"Shitor," or something.
I was singing a song and
this Scandinavian girl
was singing everything
word for word.
And she still kind of
understood what the song
was about and the vibe.
So music is now beyond language,
because music is a soul thing.
And I feel like the soul has--
There's one language
that the soul understands
and it's sound.
You know so, in that regard
I feel like you still
want to keep it original.
You still want to
keep the content 100%.
So I feel like there
shouldn't be any--
and that's just
my opinion-- there
shouldn't be any
overly intention
to water down the music.
But of course, as we
travel, like for instance,
I'm in the US now.
I'm hearing new words.
I'm hearing new music.
It will reflect in the music
and maybe it might be more--
Someone in diaspora will be
able to relate to it more.
And it's very good you
asked that question,
because I was
listening to a song,
there's a song called
"Run Up," by Major Lazer.
And he has the
Afrobeat instrumental,
but it has English
throughout in the song.
And I can see how the
song is really huge.
So it's something we've
been thinking about.
But I feel there shouldn't
be any direct watering down.
We should just follow the vibe.
If I hear the song and I decide
to sing 100% English, I will.
If I decide to mix it with
Ghana language and Nigerian
languages, it's a vibe.
People will still relate to
it as long as good music.
AUDIENCE: So we've
been celebrating
the rise of African music in
general all across the globe,
but there's been a trend and--
I know, just because I
just came out of school,
there was always
backlash about artists
like Drake using a lot
of African inflection
in how they speak
or their music.
And I wonder, as an artist,
what's your take on that,
on other artists doing that?
MR. EAZI: So I feel like to be--
If I was pissed at that
as an African artist,
then the guy out in Jamaica
should also be pissed.
And even in, like
for instance, when
I was doing mining in Ghana.
In the hinterlands of Ghana,
where there was no network.
I'm talking where we're mining
for gold deep in the Bush.
I met these guys who only
listened to country music.
They are listening to country
music in the hinterland,
and they're asking me, oh,
do you know this artist?
Do you know this artist?
And they don't even
speak, they don't even
speak proper English,
and these guys
are vibing to
country music there.
So I feel like if anything,
I think is kind of positive.
And I feel like it's left
to the African artist
to take advantage of that.
Cause let me give
you an example.
So say you might see one dance
is heavy on African influence,
and you can see
it in the groove.
And then there's a UK
artist on the record,
and there's an African
artist on the record.
And because someone like
Drake has jumped on it
and, has made it a pop
sound, someone who would have
never loved that sound,
that would have never heard
about that sound, is now
familiar with the sound.
And tomorrow, when he hears
another sound that's familiar,
he would love it.
A typical example, sometime
last year I opened my Instagram
and I saw Rita Ora
had reached out to me.
And I'm like, yo, is
this the real Rita Ora?
And then I click.
Are you the real Rita Ora?
She's like,yeah.
She sends me her
number, and then I
FaceTime to be sure
that she's the one.
I see she's the one.
But basically, how
did that happen?
She had heard a record
play on Spotify.
Right?
And this record was by,
I think maybe it was even
a Drake record, but
she heard a record that
sounded like my record.
And you know how the app just
basically randomly puts bids
on sounds related to this?
And she heard it, and she's
like, oh, what music is this?
She heard it, she was loving it.
Next thing she goes
out to social media,
she sees me there,
and she reaches out.
So I feel it is very positive
for us, and we have to ride it.
Because at the end
of the day, if you
are the source of
the sound then you
should be able to
do the sound well.
Because the source
will remain authentic.
So it's just left
for us to ride on it.
Say if I had a
record with Drake.
For instance, today I
would basically tell it--
Part of the agreement
for doing the record
will be that I will open
for you in say, 10 shows.
So any time you want to perform
10 shows, I will open for you,
and I will perform that
record with you on five shows.
And that way it's
going to help me.
It's going to help
me as an African, is
going to help the sound.
So I feel like, if anything,
we should take advantage.
And if there were any time
to market African music,
I feel this is the time.
We should be ready to
market African music
and that's what hopefully we'll
be able to do it this year.
SPEAKER: Yo.
That's exciting man.
Aren't you guys
excited about that?
You got to jump in on this.
So we have some
questions on the Dory
from people watching
from Dublin right now,
and from all our
different offices.
So we're going to jump
into some of those.
And New York.
So we'll go to New York
question from [INAUDIBLE].
She asks, what's your
creative process like?
How do you go about creating
beats, sounds, lyrics,
and where do you
draw inspiration?
MR. EAZI: Yeah, so I draw
inspiration from life,
from anything, anything random.
It could be a sound I heard
or something somebody told me.
For instance, my little
single "Leg Over,"
was basically someone who was--
[COUGHING]
Sorry.
Someone had told me about
how his girlfriend was
playing on him with somebody,
sending her money from London.
So he just told me the story.
He just told me the
story in passing.
He was just like yo,
Mr. Eazi, can you
imagine my girlfriend
has been cheating on me?
She has another guy in
London who sends her money.
And every time she
says she's going
to London to see her uncle,
she's going to see him.
And I was laughing at that.
Oh, sorry.
Sorry.
[LAUGHTER]
And then again, I
get in the studio,
and then we were
just making the beat.
And then unknowingly,
I'm exposing him.
The first thing to
come out of my head,
maybe confused me
with her [INAUDIBLE].
We should get the guy when he
send that money from London.
So I basically put his
story on the record.
I've not apologized to him.
SPEAKER: Do it right now.
Just look at the camera.
MR. EAZI: Yo, I apologize.
If I say your name now,
they will know it's you.
You know and that's
exactly how I create music.
I feel like, and
that's the reason
why I won't say I make
hit record or pop records.
I make records
people can relate to.
And so whether they are in the
club or they're in the car,
or they're at home, there's
something they can relate to.
And that's my creative process.
It's very random, very random.
SPEAKER: Yo, that's dope.
So, next question on the Dory.
African music is blowing up,
like you just talked about.
Do you think it's
going to help the image
or the way people
think about Africa?
Do you think it's going to
change Africa as a country?
$1 a day type stuff?
Anything around some
of the [INAUDIBLE]?
MR. EAZI: That's why my
team were talking about.
It still boils down to us.
For instance, if--
OK, African music is blowing up.
If say, I blow up in--
Even now, as a teaser
right now for myself,
the next video we're
going to put out from June
is for a song called "Tilapia."
And we're going to Ghana
to shoot "Tilapia."
And we're going to project.
We're going to show
Ghana as it is.
For somebody who is in
Russia listening to my music
and watching my video, he or
she will then see that wow,
this is in Ghana.
OK, maybe I need to go there.
I've heard that there's a place
we shot my video, "Skin Tight."
we shot it out was out in
the lodge just between Ghana
and I think is Burkina Faso.
They have this reserve there.
And then the owners
of the reserve
has told us that ever since
we dropped that video,
his place has been booked out.
People contacting him from
all parts of the world.
And it's only because they
saw that in the video.
Now if I decide to be,
as an African artist,
if I decide to start
shooting videos--
SPEAKER: In London.
MR. EAZI: --in London
or here, and all
I'm showing is the
big Ferrari, and some
chics just dancing around.
You know, I'm not doing
anything to help the culture
or to represent myself.
And that's what we
need to learn from,
like the dance hall artist.
The dance hall artists,
they to keep it 100.
That keep their videos as it is.
SPEAKER: You feel like
you're in Kingston.
MR. EAZI: You know, and
that's why there's--
I feel like that's why dance
hall and reggae culture
is popular because, the
artist drove the culture.
it is left to us to
actually actually do that.
SPEAKER: Awesome.
Awesome.
So final question.
Specially saved for last.
You know, some fights might
break out on this one.
From Dublin.
This is from Dublin also.
So you've infiltrated
both Ghanaian and Nigerian
industries super well.
African music
overall are, Right?
But the main question
is, which is better?
Ghana jollof or Nigeria jollof?
And for people don't know
jollof, Google can help you.
Just that's why we're here.
Just google it.
But what is better?
Ghana jollof or Niger jollof?
MR. EAZI: Man, I
feel like on a--
on a--
[LAUGHTER]
On a Saturday, on a Saturday
evening wedding in Lagos,
Nigerian jollof.
On a Friday evening,
Ghana jollof.
So at the end of the day,
depends on where you are.
On your mood.
SPEAKER: Wow.
Brilliant.
Brilliant answer.
With that, please let's
just celebrate Mr. Eazi, ,
and thank him for joining us.
[APPLAUSE]